c'est un arrêt de campagne classique le
décor idéal pour dévoiler des mesures
des deux entreprises mail annonce est
éclipsée par les images déchirantes en
provenance de l'afghanistan
des scènes impossible à ignorer c'est
tellement
c'est à briser le coeur de voir ce qui
est en train de se passer il confirme
que le canada a évacué trente quatre
membres de son personnel diplomatique et
militaire ainsi que 800 ressortissants
afghans jusqu'ici ottawa mais tient sa
promesse d'accueillir 20 mille réfugiés
et dans le chaos le sort des interprètes
afghans et du personnel local qui ont
aidé le canada et qui sont toujours
coincés dans le pays et d'un certain
même si on a suspendu notre présence
diplomatique on continue travailler avec
nos alliés et nos partenaires pour
s'assurer d'aider le plus d'argent
possible des militaires canadiens des
forces spéciales sont sur le terrain et
tente tant bien que mal de sécuriser
l'aéroport de kaboul avec les pays
alliés au travail 24 heures par jour 7
jours par semaine ce que nous n'avons
aucune halte ici et aucun pays n'a pu
anticiper et la rapidité avec laquelle
le taliban pris le contrôle et même les
gens sur le terrain ont été surpris par
la vitesse à laquelle la situation a
dégringolé le sujet s'est rapidement
imposé dans la campagne électorale et un
o'toole accuse justin trudeau ne pas
avoir vu venir retour en force des
talibans pourtant prévisible on doit
aider les les interpréteurs et les gens
sur le terrain en effe qu'à l'instinct
et médiatement malheureusement un
monsieur trudeau a fait rien si le
premier ministre avait précipité une
élection le parlement devrait se pencher
de façon urgente sur l'enjeu de
l'afghanistan les anciens militaires
canadiens qui se bat depuis des mois
pour l'évacuation des interprètes
afghans sont en colère et accusent le
gouvernement trudeau d'improviser
le plein
[Musique]
justin trudeau se défend de négliger la
gestion de cette crise je reçois les
mises à jour des développements
régulièrement excluant ce matin avec la
situation sur le terrain se détériore
très rapidement justin trudeau est forcé
de réagir les enjeux de politique
étrangère deviennent rarement la
question de l'urne mais cette crise a
quand même que l'impact elle détourne
justin trudeau de son message en ce
début de campagne ici louis blouin radio
canada montréal